[Musique]
alors amiral est ce que votre père a dit
mon seul rival c'est tintin
je crois qu'il l'a dit c'est mal rôle
dans la mort le reporting qui ne veut
pas se laisser avoir par les plus grands
et voilà ils sont je ne sais pas s'ils
connaissent tintin là c'est l'âge mais
j'en ai pas dit connaissent de gaulle
alors
oui est ce que votre père a dit on ne
devrait pas accepter de responsabilité
suprême au delà de 60 ans non il n'a pas
dit cela c'est vraiment tourner où
qu'ils sortiront tour nous est un homme
qui écoute et aux portes quelquefois
entendez mal
est ce que votre père a dit toute ma vie
je me suis fait une certaine idée de la
france tout a failli tout à faire est ce
qu il a dit toute ma vie j'ai rêvé
d'être une hôtesse de l'air non ça c'est
du très ancien qui avaient entendu cela
alors oui est ce qu il a dit si tous les
arabes d'algérie sont considérés comme
français colombey-les-deux-églises va
devenir colombey les deux mosquées non
il n'a pas dit cela ces perfides qui
leur apportent peyrefitte qui était un
ami n'a pas bien traiter deux sujets way
qui est celui de l'algérie et
le deuxième point c'est le scénar il
était sénateur en même temps des étés
amiral est ce que votre père a dit pour
faire le blocus de monaco il suffit de
deux panneaux de sens interdit
je crois pas qu'il ait dit de cette
façon ne le pensais ça non à un moment
où monaco a bougé un peu il a quand même
fermé qui a que chez qu'avec
la princesse de monaco de l'époque était
américaine d'origine
commencé à s'établir une brune une
arrivée d'affaires des états unis il
faut pas oublier que le premier ministre
monégasque c'est quand même un préfet
nommé par la france est ce que votre
père a dit françois mitterrand a tout
pour être un excellent comédien will a
dit cela paddy françois-mitterand il
disait monsieur mitterrand où françois
mitterrand aux enfants comment
françois me tire
a beaucoup de talent c'est un prince de
la parole de l'illusion est ce que votre
père a dit l'intendance suivra qui est
une phrase absolument faux ah c'est faux
il a toujours considéré que l'intendance
précédait ralliez vous à mon panache
blanc n'avait pas non plus de panache
blanc ni monaco ni panache il n'a rien
pu est ce que votre père a dit
est ce que votre père a dit si les
convoler chirac serait chef d'escadrille
non ça c'est à dire non
comment voulez vous gouverner un pays où
il existe 300 variétés de fromages la
lys à huy 280 j'aurai à l'époque il y
avait les quilles et pas guéri à
l'époque il n'y avait pas emma petit
louis est ce que votre père a dit tout
ce que j'espère c'est qu'on donnera
jamais mon nom à un porte avions une apa
il ne s'est pas occupé de cela c'est l
affaire des français après lui ce
n'était plus la chienne il a dit vive le
québec libre ça c'est vrai c'est un
délit un vraie vie c'est un peu comme un
must à ghadames il savait pas très bien
quoi dire il a vu tous ces québécois
réunis la divise le qu'avec les
messieurs qui ont dit chacun crié chat
donc en fait à chaque fois il répété
the bash et l'enthousiaste des français
libres est ce que votre père a dit moore
à céline dion non je n'y serais jamais
mort de quelqu'un c'est la personne
c'est le sort car des chiffres citation
c'est une fortification merci m et pour
être sûr de ne rien rater de
l'inaptitude abonnez vous mettez un
pouce bleus